so we've just computed a vector-valued
partial derivative of a vector-valued
function but the question is what does
this mean what does this jumble of
symbols actually mean in a you know more
intuitive geometric setting
and that has everything to do with how
you visualize the function and with this
specific function given that the input
is two-dimensional but the output is
three-dimensional and the output is more
dimensions than the input it's nice to
visualize it as a parametric surface
and the way that i do that maybe you
could call this visualizing it as a
transformation also because what i want
to do is basically think of the ts plane
think of
the ts plane
where all these input values live and
kind of think of how that's going to map
into three-dimensional space
but when i do that i'm actually going to
cheat a little bit rather than having a
separate plane off there is the ts plane
i'm going to
kind of overwrite onto the xy plane
itself and plop the ts plane down like
this
and this isn't the full ts plane this is
actually supposed to represent
just values of t that range from zero up
to three
so each tick mark on the graph here
corresponds with a half so this is one
that's two and then up here is three
same with s s also ranges from zero to
three
and the reason that i'm plopping it
inside three dimensional space to start
with kind of overwriting the xy plane
with the ts plane is just to make the
animating a little bit easier it's it's
you could call it laziness
but the benefit here is
what we can do is watch each point and
each one of these points you're thinking
of is corresponding to some kind of ts
pair an input point which is just a pair
of numbers and we're going to watch each
one of those points move to the
corresponding output right the output is
a three-dimensional value a
three-dimensional vector or point
however you want to think about it and
what that looks like when we animate
this actually
is
each one of those points in our square
of ts plane
moves to the corresponding output
and you end up with a certain surface
and just to make it a little more
concrete what's actually going on here
let's focus in on just one point
and we'll focus in on this point not
just for the function visualization but
for the partial derivative as well
and the function or the the point rather
that i care about is going to be at 1 1.
so this point right here represents the
pair
of ts
where each one of them is equal to 1
1 1.
and you can start by predicting where
you think this is going to get output
and to do that you just plug it into the
function
this is kind of what the visualization
means is we're plugging this in
and for t and s we're going to plug in
just one and one
so that top part is going to look like 1
squared minus 1 squared which becomes 0.
that middle part is going to be 1 times
1 which is 1 and then over here we're
going to have 1 times 1 squared which is
1 minus 1 times 1 squared which is again
1 and you can probably see because of
the symmetry there those also cancel out
you get 0
which means
the output corresponding with this input
should be the vector 0 1 0 a vector
that's of unit length pointing in the y
direction so if we look here you know
this is the x axis this here is the y
axis
so you would think
it should be a vector that looks kind of
like this
unit vector in the y direction and the
point of the surface is what corresponds
to the tip of that vector right this is
how we visualize parametric things you
just think of the tip of the vector as
kind of moving through space and and
drawing out the thing in this case the
thing it's drawing is a surface so if we
watch that animation again and we let
things play forward
that dot corresponding with the input 1
does indeed land at the tip of that
vector so at least for that value you
can see that i'm not lying to you with
the animation
and in principle you could do that for
every single point right if any given
input point you kind of plug it through
the function and you draw the vector in
three dimensional space as you watch
this animation it'll land at the tip of
that vector
so um now if we want to start thinking
about what the partial derivative means
remember this is this little dt this
partial t is telling you to nudge it in
the t direction so what is movement just
not even nudges but just movement in
general look like in the t direction for
our
uh our little snippet of the ts plane
here
well the the t direction
um
i'm saying is is in this direction here
where you know this this represents one
two three of t values
and
this line here represents the constant
value for s so this will be s constantly
equaling one which you can know because
it's passing through the point one one
and then otherwise you're just letting t
range freely
and if we watch how this gets
transformed under the you know under the
transformation under the mapping to the
parametric surface
you can get a feel for what varying the
input t does in the output space right
so this whole pink line
is basically telling you what happens if
you let s constantly equal one but you
let the variable t the input t vary
freely
and you get a certain curve in three
dimensional space
and you know if you had a different
constant for s it would be another curve
and maybe you can kind of see on the
grid lines what shape those other curves
would have and they're all in a sense
you know parallelish to this curve
corresponding to s equals one
so if instead of thinking about movement
of t as a whole you start thinking about
nudges
this whole partial t
um
is something where we're just imagining
a tiny tiny little movement in the t
direction not really that much just a
tiny little move and you'll you're it's
like you're recording its value as
partial t so maybe if you're being
concrete you'd say partial t would be
something like 0.01 and really it's
going to be a limiting variable that
gets smaller and smaller but i find it's
kind of nice to think about an actual
value like 1 100
and then if you if you let this whole
thing undergo the transformation we kind
of watch
watch the input point watch the line
representing t
um that little nudge that little nudge
is going to get maybe stretched or
squished and it's going to result in
some kind of vector
pointing along that curve and it'll be
tangent to that curve right the the
vector that tells you how you move just
a tiny tiny little bit it'll be tangent
in some way
and
that that
vector that output nudge is what you're
thinking of as your tiny change to the
output vector that partial v
and when you divide it by the tiny value
right if your tiny value was 0.01 and
you divide it by that it's going to
become something bigger so the the
actual derivative isn't going to be just
some tiny little nudge that's you know
hardly hardly visible but it's going to
be that that nudge vector scaled
appropriately in this case it would be
divided by 1 100 or multiplied by you
know 100 and it would be something that
remains tangent to the curve but maybe
it's pointing big and the the larger it
is right the the longer it is
that's telling you that as you let t
vary and you're kind of moving along
this pink curve tiny nudges and t
correspond with larger movements right
the ratio of the nudge sizes is bigger
so if you are if you were to have a a
very long partial derivative vector
that's still tangent but really goes out
there that would tell you that as you
vary t you're zipping along super
quickly
um and if we just look at this you know
this particular one that the stemming
off of one you kind of get a feel for
the curve around that point you say okay
okay and that curve you're moving
positively in the x direction right
you're moving to the right um you're
moving positively in the z direction
you're not z sorry the y positively in
the y direction up there
and the z direction is actually negative
isn't it this curve kind of goes down as
far as z is concerned so before even
computing it if i were to tell you that
i'm going to plug in the value 1 1 to
this partial derivative that we that we
computed in the last video you would say
oh well just looking at the picture you
can kind of tell that the x value is
going to be something positive something
greater than zero the y value is also
going to be something positive and again
that's because you know the movement is
to the right so positive x it's moving
up so positive y but the z value should
actually be a little bit negative right
because
as you look at this curve it's going
down in a sense
and with that being our prediction if
you start plugging in 1 1 to t and s
what you'll see
is that you know two times one is two
s equals one so that's just one and then
over here this this looks like one
squared minus two times one times one so
this will be one minus two that's
negative 1.
so it is in fact that kind of positive
positive negative pattern that you're
seeing and maybe maybe even from this
curve you can get a feel for why the
movement in the x direction is twice as
much as the movement in the y
it's it's moving more to the right than
it is up in the y direction
and again in principle you can imagine
doing this not just at the point 1 1 but
at any given point maybe any given point
along this curve or any given point
along the surface
and
the corresponding movement the direction
that you know nudges in the t direction
t q will give you some vector in three
dimensional space and that's the
interpretation that is the
uh
the meaning of the partial derivative of
the
vector valued function here um and again
it's it's not the tiny the actual nudge
vector itself right when you nudge the
input and you get just a little smidgen
in the output space here but it's that
divided by the size of the nudge so
that's why you'll get kind of normal
size vectors rather than tiny vectors
and in the next video i'll do kind of
the same thing for what happens when you
nudge in the s direction just to get a
better feel for what's going on in this
example